the starford lighting update is actually
very impressive check this out these
images are from D disco on Reddit and
they show massive differences in
Lighting in Starfield from beta update
which is 1.9.4 7.0 like look at this it
almost looks like a completely different
game that's like not even slightly
similar they made it way more neon way
more like cyberpunky this one I think is
one of my favorites it's so much more
depth to it it doesn't look as sterile
which I think might have been like one
of my criticism with the game there's a
really nice reflection on this one that
wasn't there before which just I think
gives it like way more depth in this
back area and makes it look like a much
bigger environment this one I actually
don't know if I like the before or after
better this is before this is after it
definitely looks different I'm just not
sure if I prefer it this one too they
just made it way like clearer
unfortunately I can only show you a tiny
bit of the images because of the way
shorts scaling works so I'll leave a
link in the description to where you can
check out the full post on the subreddit
if you want to see more